NORMALIZE THEIR RELATIONS AND
HAVE THE AMBASSADORS BACK AND
FORTH TO OPEN UP DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS.
MANY MEETINGS AHEAD.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
FORMER ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT, DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA
AND RETIRED SEAT BY A SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER, DANIEL
HOFFMAN.
I'M PROUD TO ANNOUNCE THAT BOTH
OF THEM WILL BE WITH THIS
PROGRAM IN SINGAPORE.
SARAH CARTER WILL BE THERE AS
WELL, AS OF COURSE THE IG
REPORT, TWO DAYS AFTER THE
SINGAPORE SUMMIT.
LOTS OF GROUND TO COVER TONIGHT.
LET'S START WITH YOU DANIEL
HOFFMAN.
THE PRESIDENT SHOWING STRENGTH,
I WILL WALK AWAY ANY TIME.
IT'S RIGHT OUT OF THE ART OF THE
DEAL, IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
I BELIEVE I KNOW HIM WELL ENOUGH
TO KNOW THAT HE WOULD ABSOLUTELY
WALK AWAY IN FOUR SECONDS.
>> I THINK HE IS ALSO DOING THE
RIGHT THING BY MANAGING
EXPECTATIONS, HE'S DEALING WITH
DECADES OF FAILED POLICY, FROM
WHICH WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT.
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
SUNSHINE POLICY WHICH WAS MORE
LIKE THE MOONSHINE POLICY FOR
NORTH KOREA AT THE END OF THAT
10-YEAR PERIOD, WHEN THEY HAD
TAKEN $3 BILLION FROM
SOUTH KOREA AND ALMOST
$2 BILLION FROM CHINA, INCREASED
OF THE NUCLEAR PROGRAM
SIGNIFICANTLY, AND WE HADN'T
BEEN A COLORIZED OR TAKEN MANY
STEPS TO DO NEWCO RISE THE
PENINSULA.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN ON BOARD
ALL OF THOSE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE PAST AND I THINK HE IS
REALLY WELL PREPARED TO GO
FORWARD WITH A REALLY BOLD
STRATEGY FOR DEALING WITH THIS
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE WILL BE
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
COUNTRIES FROM THE SIX PARTY
TALKS LIKE RUSSIA AND CHINA WHO
ARE MEDDLING, AND NOT ALWAYS
HELPFUL ON THE PART OF RUSSIA TO
SOLVING THE CRISIS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW SOMETHING
COME UP THE WORLD WOULD BE A LOT
BETTER OFF IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
KIM JONG UN AND THE KOREAN
PENINSULA THREATENED BY
NORTH KOREA.
AND ENDING THE KOREAN WAR,
DR. GORKA SEEMS TO ME TO BE A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA AND WOULD BE
GOOD FOR THE WORLD.
WE HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
KIM JONG UN WILL TALK ABOUT
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION OF HIS
REGIME.
GOOD FOR THE WORLD.
>> AFTER 65 YEARS, ABSOLUTELY.
JUST THE ABSURDITY THAT THIS WAR
IS STILL REALLY, ACCORDING TO
THE LACK OF A PEACE TREATY, IN
EFFECT.
IT'S JUST A CEASE-FIRE.
SO, YEAH, LET'S DO IT.
LET'S GO THERE, BUT STAY NUCLEAR
AS THE PENINSULA.
THIS ISN'T A DICTATORSHIP THAT
WILL FALL TOMORROW.
IT WON'T SOLVE ALL OF THE
PENINSULA'S PROBLEMS, BUT IF
ANYONE CAN END THE WAR OR DO YOU
NEED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: AGREED.
IT DOESN'T CONCERN YOU THAT A
REPORTER'S NOTES AND SOURCES AND
EVERYTHING DOJ HAS OBTAINED,
DR. GORKA, INSTINCTIVELY THIS
SOUNDS REALLY BAD TO ME.
>> I DON'T CARE IF THEY'RE
PRESIDENT IS A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT OR WHO THE REPORTER
WORKS FOR.
THAT AMOUNT OF INFORMATION BEING
DEMANDED OR CAPTURED FROM THE
DOJ COME ON WHAT BASIS?
>> Sean: AND AT THE BAR IS
VERY HIGH, AS WE KNOW.
ALL RIGHT, I WILL GET TO BE WITH